I want to throw it to uh uh our good
friend Dave Chappelle
Daily Mail says what the f happened to
this place Dave Chappelle slams San
Francisco as half Glee half zombie movie
as surprise gig as he recalls homeless
person defecating outside Indian
restaurant he was about to eat in
Dave Chappelle's a normal guy he's not
conservative he's not he's not right
he's not left he's he was very critical
of Candace Owens but when you get
someone like Dave Chappelle looking
around and then sang to everybody what
the f happened to this place and they
all laugh because they feel the same way
I feel like we're winning I mean well
actually I feel like we're losing I hope
he added his account people are waking
up to it I hope he added that encounter
to the Poop Map in San Francisco it's
like part of the red red dot i i
retweeted something that CNN had had uh
posted about the multitude of businesses
that had left uh left San Francisco and
I said it's because of crime and I got
pushed back from some of my friends and
they're like how do you know it's like
look all of the things that you can come
up with that reasons why retailers are
having problems and stuff they're all
real right but at the end of the day if
you have to buy cases for literally
everything in your store and so you can
lock it up and you still get people
coming in there and and stealing things
that means you have to worry about
liability for your people that are
working there the it is it is absolutely
I can't imagine how someone would say
that it's not the crime being the
deciding factor businesses absorb all
sorts of costs all the time taxes in in
San Francisco it's not like it's cheap
to do business in San Francisco the
overhead has got to be a nightmare but
at the end of the day if you can't put
people in the store without worrying
about an interaction with criminals you
know without actually worrying about
people getting injured then you're not
going to have businesses doing business
in that location that's all there is to
it and it's ridiculous to a restaurant
too yeah it's ridiculous to try to argue
anything else
do you feel like you'd ever go back to
City I know you're in DC but you grew up
in Chicago right yes I grew up in the
south side of Chicago so I'm pretty
familiar with terrible places across
the the people in China normally I'm
saying it well aim it's true it's true
it's not a fun place to be I don't like
being uh outside at night for too long
well but like it's the interesting thing
about it is when you grow up with it you
feel like it's normal you know what I
mean yeah yeah I interviewed a couple
that were from South Africa and they
said it's not as bad as people think
we've only been carjacked I think five
times and I was like what wow like but
you you're it's normal to you as bad as
it is you can only get murdered once
yeah that's it so but attempted murder
can happen a lot that's how scary it is
in Chicago I just feel like all these
stories are reasons why people will
rethink cities I mean if you have like a
young teenager right and they want to go
to college and they're like I want to go
to school in New York or San Francisco
if you're a parent are you just letting
them I mean you can't make decisions
more than they're adults but like yeah I
think would you be okay with that
absolutely not I just I can't imagine
trying to start any kind of family in
these cities is terrible I take the
jackposovic advice and get out yeah I
mean that's what I've been saying for a
long time I I do feel like when it comes
to the penny case one of the things that
that got me to come around was
let's keep the fight in the city so it's
not out here because we are starting to
see some of this pop up in the more
rural areas you know I'm in Eastern
panhandle of West Virginia and you've
got people from DC who go there to
escape what they've created but then
they bring those policies with them
because they're not smart enough to
realize they created them they're like
let's bring all this policies here and
so it's kind of like can we can we keep
the focus in the cities and then you
know what maybe even win some present at
the larger level also I think defend uh
protecting self-defense is imperative
this this case with Penny isn't just
about him personally first and foremost
it is after after that it's we have to
absolutely make sure that any issue of
self-defense we win yeah if you want to
if you have any desire to protect your
second amendment rights you absolutely
must protect your right to defend your
own life with your hands like if you
have any hope of saving your your right
to own a firearm to defend yourself you
have to make sure that your personal
safety is your our own property and you
are allowed to defend it if if you if we
if you lose that then you lose basically
any rights to property at all that means
they'll take your you know taking
everything from you if they want to the
the question I have with the store with
Dave Chappelle is I I said it feels like
we're winning I said well actually it
feels like we're losing but at least
people are waking up to it the first
step in changing the stuff is regular
people saying okay hey wait something
bad is going on here the question then
becomes Dave Chappelle
doing a a comedy bit where he tells
people who live there
it's bad and they all laugh
does that mean any of them will spur to
action to stop this
because if the answer is no then we're
doomed I think it's no yeah I'm pretty
black pilled I think it's also known I
think that there are so many people who
think it's normal right like you don't
notice how bad it's getting until you
leave I was who was here uh one of the
comedians was here you'll know his name
he's a Libertarian guy and Dave Smith
yeah he was here he was talking about
how he moved out of the city during
covid and then he went back for some
reason was like I don't remember how bad
this was like this seems like it's got
suddenly gotten worse but it's because
you walk past it every day and you're
used to it I think that's part of this
like if you tell a crowd people who live
in San Francisco yeah your homeless
problems homeless population is really a
problem and they're it's kind of erratic
Behavior they're like I know crazy right
anyways like it's just a lot of usual a
lot of the denser urban areas in the
South Side closer and close to downtown
in Chicago I often felt smelled like
sour milk I don't know if you ever
noticed that I had the taco smell Taco
smell I mean Taco smells pretty good
though over there it's great yeah but
and then in New York a lot of sour milk
too and I don't know exactly why but
that's why I also make the joke living
in a concrete block stack on top of each
other smelling like sour milk because
there are these areas that for some
reason do I think with Chicago for me it
was because there were some schools and
they would dump milk out like literally
so it smelled like sour milk I smelled
that all over New York like just trash
and sour milk kind of smell and and in
New York they put the garbage in front
of their houses
that's easy that is weird right because
being braced alleys exactly in Chicago
we have alleys so you put your garlic
out of mind yeah and then the the
garbage trucks go through the alleys to
pick up all the trash New York they
don't have that coyote way so dude go to
go to the go to Occupy Wall Street the
zuccotti park where that was going down
and there's like a five foot tall pile
of garbage outside of these restaurants
because they got nowhere that's where
they put it and then it just it's all
piled up in the streets and the garbage
trucks come to take it it's it's nasty
it looks like Paris you know is that
what Paris is like yeah because they're
all those protesters there and uh
they're mad about their retirement age
oh yeah I think the main smell in
Chicago is fear and anxiety always
having a you know look over my shoulder
and make sure no one's following me yeah
that's true but then they vote for you
know Brandon Johnson so I'm not quite
sure very true it matters yeah yeah it's
like just when you think you thought you
could save the city you had some sliver
of an opportunity to go to you know Paul
vallis you know but Brandon Johnson is
worse than Lori Lightfoot this is part
of what makes me black pilled on the
city and people who live there and it's
why last week I was like I don't know I
don't want to be involved in this thing
I do think winning uh on a self-defense
case in New York means winning for us I
do think Daniel Penny should not be in
prison I do think him winning his case
that's precedent about the value of far
left protests and diminishes them at the
same time though I still have to say
these people in these cities like Dave
Chappelle points out they still do
nothing
yeah it's extremely frustrating I mean I
both we're both from Chicago part of
what made me a republican was being from
Chicago you know getting out of the city
and looking back as you said it's it is
an eye-opener to see what you've gotten
used to were you a Republican when you
grew up there
um I I really well I wasn't uh I was
really thinking about it that much until
I was going off into college and
thinking about my own life in the world
outside of Chicago and realized it
didn't have to be this way and do you
feel like people you grew up with are
similarly money feel like they're kind
of like oh this is just the way life is
yeah yeah I do think that they they feel
like that that's the way life is and
they've been so co-opted by this strange
Democrat message of you know if you're
the Democrat you're the good guy and the
Republicans are always the bad guy
because those are the party of white
guys and US minority you know the party
of minorities or can never do anything
wrong on the Democrats that's actually
because of Jon Stewart yeah Jon Stewart
made made Republicans and and
conservative ideas toxic but not
actually the idea it's gonna have to
take a lot to get these people to wake
up I don't know how much longer I don't
I don't know if if they will because so
much of their of their lives is just
predicated upon tribal social adherence
that's what I call the woke cult the
adherence to left liberal social
Orthodoxy with cult like fervor it
doesn't matter what's true it just
matters that they say the thing that is
right even if it's insane
yes how do you snap someone out of that
you have to you have to have the
Integrity to say no to that to begin
with you have to be the kind of person
sitting at your computer at work and
then someone says did you hear that
Donald Trump said white nationalists are
very fine people you have to be the
person that goes no that's not true he
didn't say that yeah I think we all have
to be cool they should be totally
condemned it can they should be totally
condemned
they're just saying some nonsense there
in the news you have to be willing to
stand up and say God you can't just say
that that's not true a lot of people on
the left don't know what is actually
true because they believe things that
propagandists tell them if you go
through Twitter right now there's a lot
of people retweeting uh things that
people said in like 2019 2018 because of
the whole Durham thing that came out
today you know people like Ezra Klein
and FBI that are people that you're
supposed to respect they are the there
are
a innumerable propagandists and the left
is so uninterested in hearing opposing
views that they fall into the the
narratives that are totally unbelievable
and and I think that that's no go ahead
well I think that I think that that you
need to give people that have been fed a
load of propaganda for a lot for as long
as you can remember you have to give
them a way out so it's like you want to
be like I totally agree you do have to
be like no no that's not true but you
don't want to come at someone without
giving them a way to walk it back and be
like oh okay so you know it's like it's
better to look at it like a joke and and
give them an out so that way they don't
feel like you're gonna stomp on them for
for being like oh maybe I was wrong
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
Joseph
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time